merci monsieur le premier mini dont la
parole est à mme heuzé martial saddier
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
en 2004
sur le premier disque sous l'impulsion
du gouvernement de jean pierre raffarin
nous avons lancé une nouvelle politique
industrielle au coeur de laquelle se
trouvent les pôles de compétitivité
l'esprit qui animait la création de cet
outil est le suivant ce n'est qu'en
amenant et en soutenant l'innovation et
la recherche dans nos entreprises que
nous doperont la croissance et donc la
création d'emplois depuis les
gouvernements successifs ont toujours
soutenu de façon indéfectible
les pôles de compétitivité or monsieur
le premier ministre depuis quelques mois
votre gouvernement nous donne des
signaux quelque peu alarmant en effet
les chefs d'entreprise les entreprises
les pôles de compétitivité mais aussi
plus largement l'ensemble des clusters
des grappes d'entreprise s'inquiètent
quant à leur avenir et craignent un
éventuel abandon de ces outils qui
pourtant ont prouvé leur efficacité en
témoigne une région parmi tant d'autres
la belle réussite des pôles de
compétitivité en région auvergne
rhône-alpes première source d'inquiétude
monsieur le premier ministre si la loi
notre a opéré dès janvier 2010 est un
transfert de compétences des
départements aux régions dans le domaine
économique
ce texte a délibérément omis d'évoquer
la question du financement de ce
transfert qui n'est en rien réglé à ce
jour entre les départements et les
régions
seconde source d'inquiétude depuis
maintenant six mois
votre gouvernement nous annonce une
nouvelle vision pour l'emploi et plus
particulièrement pour les pôles de
compétitivité vision qui pour l'heure
reste complètement et totalement floues
que vont devenir les pôles quelle est la
position de l'état et le rôle des
régions à vos yeux dans ce domaine
monsieur le premier ministre
afin de lever cette grande inquiétude
pouvez-vous nous réaffirmer votre
intérêt pour l'emploi le développement
économique et votre soutien sans faille
en faveur des pôles de compétitivité
pouvez vous éclairer la représentation
nationale sur la vision de votre
gouvernement et surtout nous assurer du
maintien du financement des pôles de
compétitivité dans notre pays mais aussi
la parole est à monsieur emmanuel macron
ministre de l'économie de l'industrie et
du numérique
monsieur le président
monsieur le député saddier je veux ici
reconnaître avec vous en effet la
pertinence que représentent les pôles de
compétitivité qui a conduit gouvernement
après gouvernement à maintenir ce
dispositif qui permet d'animer des
écosystème d'innovation de production
industrielle vous en avez cité un parmi
d'autres
le pôle de la vallée de l'arve également
en mécatronique est particulièrement
important pour toutes les pme de la
vallée et vous le savez bien
notre intention n'est pas de supprimer
cette organisation simplement c'est de
reconnaître comme je pense vous pouvez
le reconnaître avec nous qu'elle nie
mais au niveau du gouvernement ou d'un
ministère plus de soixante dix pôles de
compétitivité ça n'est pas réaliste et
c'est en quelque sorte la résultante
d'un non choix français d'une habitude
que nous avons prise à défaut d'avoir
quelques priorités
eh bien nous dispersons et donc notre
volonté c'est d'une part de définir des
priorités claires c'est ce que nous
avons fait dans le cadre de la nouvelle
france industrielle pour monter en gamme
différencier aider à investir à
accompagner autour d'une matrice
industries du futur et de neuf priorités
puis ensuite c'est d'évaluer n'y a pas
de solution miracle mais c'est regarder
ce qui fonctionne bien et moins bien et
de conduire a réorganisé ses pôles à
l'issue de dix ans de fonctionnement
il ya eu plusieurs évaluations il y a
aujourd'hui une évaluation consensuel
partager avec les régions puisque c'est
une démarche que nous conduisons avec
les régions pour regarder justement
l'épaule qui fonctionne bien et moins
bien
aucun pôles de compétitivité ne sera
supprimé notre intention est au maximum
de déléguer la gestion et l'animation de
ces pôles de compétitivité aux régions
avec lés crédits y afférents et c'est
d'organiser comme j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire il ya quelques semaines en
compagnie de jean michel baylet lorsque
nous avons annoncé cette initiative est
bien d'organiser sur le territoire en
quelque sorte l'organisation entre ces
pôles pour que neuf à dix d'entre eux
puissent être corde